هل في اعتقادك ستتمكن هذه العمليه من
ايقاف هجمات الحوثيين على السفن
الاسرائيليه في البحر
الاحمر يعني شخصيا لا اعتقد
ا اولا هذه الضربات الامريكيه كانت مقصوده
ان لا تكون ضخمه صحيح انها متعدده واصابت
اهداف
عديده في مدن مختلفه لكن ليست ليست بالحجم
الذي يدمر قوه الحوثيين العسكريه لا سما
البحريه منها والمنتشره في سواحل اليمن
على البحر الاحمر وبالتالي اظن ان هذه
الضربه هي بقدر ما فيها رساله رجعيه يعني
هي نعم مدمره لبعض المواقع لكنها في
النهايه تستهدف الردع وارسال رساله الى
الحوثي ان الامر يمكن ان يشمل اهداف اكثر
وبضربه اقوى ان استمرت الضربات الحوثيه
للسفن اعتقد ان رد الحوثي سيكون بالتاكيد
سيحصل سيحصل هناك رد حوثي سيحصل وربما
سيجعل
من البحر الاحمر كله ساحه لحرب باعتبار او
على الاقل منع جميع السفن من المرور عبر
باب المندب وبالتالي ستتسع دائره
الاستهدافات الحوثيه من الس المتجهه الى
اسرائيل الى جميع السفن الداخله في باب
الندب